seconds did you ever think you
make Victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David valueing giving values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters how run homie
look what I become I'm the I'm the one
Rob yeah feel free to take picks cuz I
can't and I'll post them there you go I
think the opening line today for
everybody to know is today this morning
uh uh Tom came in prepared to piss
everybody off he comes in one of our
girls just got her Masters and he's like
this is something these guys will know
nothing about nothing and he goes like
this and he looked and he made a second
comment by the way offending you a
little bit I don't know if you caught
that what was the second one you don't
remember that how he said it very
offensive but anyways Tom you okay today
Tom are we good are you off like to a
bad start did you not have your weedies
is yeah what
happened what was that that's an
Elwood white guy that was a Hollywood
delayed L anyway all right we got a
guest today with us I am fine and too
much is being made of that but you want
to rip it up for the next two hours oh
Tom don't fall for Tom's trap Tom is
actually officially pissed Tom is what
he is no Tom's going pissed since
yesterday's pbd podcast prep anyways
okay today we have Emily Austin with us
okay she's a Prof talker we learn
in the first 20 minutes she's capable
like witty right off the bat uh American
journalist social media influencer model
actress and independent NBA broadcaster
born in 2001 maybe you're probably the
only guest we've had that's born in the
2000 yes have we had anybody born in
2000 I think she's trying to give you a
high five no no no I'm not going to be
left hanging was oh I'm sorry I thought
you were like going like this like
Yay give me one of these things give me
one of careful the hand raises at so
born in 2001 United States to Israeli
parents Emily grew up on Long Island
studied at hofra University very
competitive she joined Israeli mission
to the UN where she handles English
Communications and public relations
written all over the place been on Fox
with gutfield it's good to have you on
thanks for having me yes so here the
last couple months you've been
everywhere and Rob says Pat you got to
check her out so we do and then Rob says
let's get on the podcast and here you
are amazing shout out to Rob yeah so
we're going to go through a lot of
different stories today uh some of the
stories I got folks we got Trump being
banned from Colorado ballot which we
have to cover that we will houti attacks
on commercial ships if you haven't seen
the video of them coming down on the
ship and a helicopter and what it's
doing to the Red Sea some of the data
we'll cover that a lot of elitists from
with master's degree know a lot about
that story and then we'll cover Russia
try to weaken Democrats ahead of 2022
midterms us spy agency says that's a wsj
story China Russia Iran and Cuba tried
metalink in Congressional elections
migrant surges insane Rob I don't know
if you found that video or not Vic
stunts CNN van Jones tell them to go
shut the f up and then Graham we'll talk
about Israel some of the things that's
going on right now with Israel what
they're asking forcing both sides more
media layoffs um in uh it's not looking
good percentage wise on the number of
journalists being laid off is pretty
nasty in the mainstream media space fed
official rate Cuts maybe we'll cover
that nipping steel to acquire us steel
time you got some updates there
Southwest did you guys hear about
Southwest is officially folks some good
news is giving free extra seats to obese
people what if I identify as obese maybe
you get three of them maybe you get
three of them maybe get three of them if
you identify that's a technical question
we'll address I'm sure Tom will know the
answer to it uh us Economist predicts
2024 will bring the biggest crash of our
lifetime that there's a little bit of
fear porn when you read the story on
what the percentage who said that Robert
K but Harry Dan we'll cover it we'll
cover it stock market you guys may be
surprised by this the the performance of
the stock market under Biden remains
worse than Trump and Obama very
surprising even with the big bouns but
there's this thing called biomics we'll
cover that b inflation that's right B
inflation over one-third of companies
will not give a urine bonus I'll give
you guys a story by when the Trump tax
cuts came that's a good story we're not
doing any bonuses this year only if you
have only to the to the community with
Masters because you have to given
definitely over over 170 people with
Epstein links likely to be named in
courts docs set to be unsealed in um
coming weeks a lot of people nervous
about this then there's this Miss
Universe judge okay I don't know if you
know her or not she was hit with death
threats after debate against Palestinian
activists and Miss Universe judge said
transgender contestant led to bankruptcy
so let's start off with that I don't
know her but she sounds really hot yeah
she is actually and by the way it took
two seconds for Vinnie to flirt with you
how awesome is that wasn't flirting with
her she came out and Vinnie half the
time everybody thinks you're flirting
with them but we have to kind of
categorize Vinnie it speaks for itself
it's it's a natural flirt okay here we
go Miss Universe judge says transgender
contestant led to bankruptcy uh Emily
Austin attributed to pageant bankruptcy
to outrage over transgender contestants
stating I think the outrage about a
transwoman coming to Miss Universe and
preaching bringing the power back to
women couldn't be more of an oxy
she expressed her belief that allowing
transgender women to participate was
both socially and morally wrong adding
people are starting to catch onto that
Austin highlighted the financial issues
faced by the company under the ownership
of tha media Mogul and transwoman and
can't pronounce the last name who
purchased the rights to Miss Universe
missusa and miss teen in 2022 to $420
million she mentioned the company's
failure to fulfill a $2 million loan
debt anyways we know the story here uh
give us a little bit about about
background with the story there and why
you think this uh brand called Miss
Universe 72y old brand is getting
destroyed by this person here I mean
growing up I loved Miss Universe for
God's sake when I was not even 18 I ran
for Miss New York I thought it was the
coolest thing ever because Miss Universe
should be an example of what a woman
should be to the world like the prime
example of a woman and when I say woman
I mean a biological one and everyone's
been calling me transphobic and trans
every nasty word you can possibly be
called but it's quite simple my theory
and if you actually listen with your
ears you'll likely agree I don't care
what you identify as you want to
identify as a cat so be it I think
you're a weirdo but it's not my problem
but now you're crossing a boundary where
you are threatening women's empowerment
which is what Miss Universe is preaching
and you are saying this person who grew
up a man never knew what a period cramp
felt like never knew what you know like
all the awkward puberty things and and
awkward things that women have to deal
with okay you don't know what that feels
like the same way I don't know what it's
like to be like a man truly biologically
but the fact that you want identify now
halfway through your life or whatever
point and say I deserve this more than a
biological woman now you're Bering woman
and that's not fair same thing in sports
you know uh in 2012 a video surface of
Serena Williams saying oh if I played
XYZ she was speaking about a male
athlete he would destroy minutes six and
he wasn't even the greatest she's the
greatest he was he was a top 10 guy but
yeah you're right she's number one
without a doubt sense you know
biologically I'm sorry we are not the
same and you can identify as whatever
you want but just stop pretending it's
the same because it's not and that's
what I keep saying to Miss Universe it's
not the same the year I was a judge
there were no trans contestants I would
not have been okay with that that was
2022 2023 there was two contestants out
of I believe 80 women or three maybe the
one snuck one in at the end but y but
Emily here's my question though what how
how is this small minority group just so
protected and so they basically just do
whatever they want if you and if you
criticize them at all you can't you
can't say anything against them not even
you can't even be funny you can't even
crack jokes everybody turns on you and
you get canceled I mean I think that's
our fault not like us in this room but
it's our fault cuz we're allowing it
everyone's like you're never going to
make it because you're you're everyone
calls me misc conservative nobody even
knows my political values which is funny
um you're against trans you're against
gays no first of all I make jokes about
everyone I make Jew jokes I'll make like
every joke to every Community cuz it's a
joke so relax but the the second we
start censoring ourselves because of
their response you're enabling them to
cancel you be uncan and you won't get
canceled I know it's probably easier
said than done but why are we silencing
ourselves like look at Chris deia
comedian right yeah he was cancelled so
many times but he's killing it on
Netflix on world tours like he didn't
let himself get canceled Dave pornoy
every week someone's trying to cancel
him doesn't let it happen so why are we
the ones censoring our own free speech
in the best country in the world when we
have it just don't it's really that a
lot of people are wearing uh being
cancelled as a badge of honor these days
it's like you know once twice you tried
but you said that it's all our fault for
sort of being complicit in this I would
argue that it's women's fault here me
out I don't know a lot of men at least
in those circles that I'm in and it's
not like I'm in I'm in the left I'm in
the right I'm everywhere I'm doing I
don't know a lot of men they're like
yeah women should men can totally
compete in this I know a lot of women
that don't speak out about this and
they'll do cuz I've interviewed
countless amounts of women on this on my
other show and the women at least off
camera would agree yeah I don't really
like this but on camera they're like
yeah I don't really want to talk about
it so I think it's a comment on women
like what you're doing to stand up and
saying no I don't want you in my pageant
right because when men say it we we'll
sound misogynistic or chauvinist toxic
yeah or toxic but they're taking over
your contest they're taking over your
sports I think
women speak out more I agree with you
100% when it comes to Miss Universe
people were challenging me hard on it
cuz they were saying this is a pageant
about looks now I thought so as well
until I became a judge once I became a
judge I really tried to listen to the
interviews and be like who has a story
that's so inspiring that I want the
world to hear MH and that's where I
realized okay this is not about looks
cuz let's be real the woman who wins is
not the prettiest woman every year at
all okay if it was the prettiest woman
it would have been miss Columbia in my
year she was by far the most beautiful
I've every year by the way every year
Columbia so gorgeous and with that being
said you know with sports and and Miss
Universe I even think they're
incomparable it's the same issue it's a
common denominator but Sports is just
biologically you're going to be
humiliated if if you play a transgender
woman AKA biological man St Universe
like vanney argued on Fox no it's about
looks no it's not it's it's never been
about looks it's always the interview so
you know you need a true feminism story
not like well let's be clear looks is a
if it's not number one it's number 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 winner by the way is the winner
was actually a girl from no no no that
was 2022 and 2023 was actually a girl
from Nicaragua you know shock alert
friend of a friend shenise from um
Nicaragua classy sexy smart she crushed
it and you know nobody no nobody's
saying we mentioned on the on the show M
it's why don't the trans Community L
start your own I'm always love start
your own trans Universe trans League
trans Sports trans UFC trans swimming Do
Your Own Thing why are you guys trying
to infiltrate everybody else's have
one create have a blue ocean go create
your own women Vinnie they're
women Vinnie That's The Logical end
argument so there's there's truth in
what you say but that's the logical end
argument the front end is what is what
gets missed in this it is a leftist
socialist Marxist agenda find a victim
and leverage it and if there is no
victim you have to create a victim yeah
and if you take a look at the
opportunistic rotation of how leftists
have taken victims and groups and
leverage for what they want what they
want to do is is drop the walls and
undermine the traditions and the
stability of the country that's the
leftist agenda they don't care about
about trans so let's go take a look you
go back and look at it George Floyd it
was overblown you be the the whole um
the part that was over a guy died a guy
died with the cop right there that day
and there was a court case and
everything that went with it but all the
BLM stuff was was sort of one side of
the reaction was overblown because it
was misinterpreting analysis on the
other side of it says why is the media
jumping on this let's focus on that the
media was jumping on it because there's
the victim there's the leverage there's
the point Marxist social leftist agenda
you have to find a victim and leverage
it and right now but these communities
don't see that they're being a pawn in a
bigger agenda how do you not see it they
think it's my turn in the spotlight it's
not your turn in the spotlight you're
being used as a victim which is not a
great pink how was that enablement
you're down you're terrible they they've
done this to you you're oppressed you're
oppressed they so they destroy your
personhood they destroy your value you
can't do anything yourself you need us
to be working for you wait a minute be
careful what they're working on they're
not really working for you and you're
going to rotate out next year all right
let's go to the next door here so again
with you Miss Universe judge hit with
death threats I think you even called
the FBI you reported this FBI after
debate against Palestinian activists you
will be killed this is November 24th uh
Emily auson faced death threats after
heated a debate with Palestinian
activist nardine kiswani over the Gaza
conflict kiswani leader of within our
lifetime United for Palestine uh
expressed support for violence against
Israel and called for the vilification
and expulsion of Zionist Austin
described Kwan's confrontational
Behavior Uh during the debate
highlighting how kwani posted a picture
of her with a red arrow over my head on
Instagram and encouraged putting a
bounty on my head Austin received death
threats such as I'll kill you and you
will be killed in the next few days so
tell us about this
experience um to be polite nerine is one
of the most disgusting vile people that
walks this Earth and I'm disgusted that
New York is not taking action against
her borderline terrorism going around
the city for context within our lifetime
is shortened for destroy Israel within
our lifetime and that's their goal and
it's not just Israel it's anyone who
believes that Israel has a right to
exist so now you are inciting violence
upon anyone who believes Israel has the
right to exist which is most Jews and a
lot of non-jews too so with that being
said on our debate I came with the fact
she came with emotional screaming I if I
were her I'd leave humiliated to and her
and her vile group of Zionist
destructors were posting like Target
this company Target Puma Target this and
she made a map of places to Target and
she put a photo of myself and Pierce
with red targets over her head and she
said don't forget like these two and
then she said later it was a joke but I
had congressman and councilwoman and New
York Executives messaging me this is not
a joke like I'll help you report it to
the FBI and I want to just really really
really shout out the FBI I've called
them at 6:00 in the morning I've called
it 1: in the morning and they've always
been available at every hour to check
the credibility of these threats so some
they'll be like hey this guy's in Saudi
Arabia don't worry then he's like all
right this girl is in Staten Island
we're going to check it out for you so
you know initially I wasn't even afraid
I'm like everyone's a keyboard Warrior
everyone has something to say behind the
screen and nobody does something in
front of it but who wants to find out
you know so of course I hired private
security and I'm like I'm going into
Manhattan This Woman nerine This monster
is terrorizing the city and now my face
is so out there because of her why
should I take a chance when I see these
people are burning trees punching each
other hitting policemen they are hitting
policemen how what do you think they're
going to do to me so I I just wanted to
take the safer route and higher security
Emily where do you where do you draw the
line on Free Speech obviously we're you
know we're fan of what uh Elon Musk has
done with X Twitter and you know I'm
sort of a free speech absolutist I'm
Jewish but I've heard some vile vile
about me and just about Jews in
general and you know but there's been no
death threats or there's been no attacks
so I'm the type of person that's like
all right cool you know thanks buddy I'm
myself yeah where do you stand on
this between Free Speech hate speech and
actual you know calls for AC of violence
how do you distinguish between all those
yeah well those are distinguishable I
mean free speech I'm a free speech
absolutist too in fact like I don't like
most things that I hear on a daily basis
but I can't start censoring things I
disagree with like we'll get into the
Trump ballots um
so you could say the most vile things
about Jews everyone's like Hitler was
right Hitler should have finished the
job but if you start to even incite that
you are going to take an action like I
will finish Hitler's job that's already
actionable that's already inciting
violence and that's where I draw the
line but free speech you can say
whatever you want and by the way saying
whatever you want doesn't mean there's
no consequences if you're calling for
Jewish genocide on college campuses
there should be a consequence the same
way if I misgender someone on college
campuses I know there will be
consequences I mean I laughed at my
classmate who identified as a cat
because that's funny and I got in
trouble but if she said from The River
To The Sea Palestine will be free of
Jewish people she would be fine so why
do you think there's such a double
standard exactly you just use my why do
you think there's such a double standard
where whether it's fat phobia gender
phobia transphobia all that you don't
you know don't offend anybody it back to
you if you call
for I think it's because the Jewish
people don't live in the victim
mentality back to his point Jewish
people don't like I mean I'm not
speaking on behalf of the Jewish people
but I'm assuming nobody should want to
live in the victim mentality listen the
Jews went through the Holocaust
throughout time and time again the Jews
are constantly being persecuted and they
always Prevail whatever the reason is
and you know the Holocaust was not even
100 years ago and Jews are never looked
at as a victims and I'm happy with that
I'm okay with that but when it comes to
like instances like these that we're
seeing in present times I've never seen
an extent of anti-Semitism this bad but
now it's like I don't know if we're not
vocal enough I don't know if we're not
causing enough outrage I mean we're not
ransacking stores and burning down
stores and you meanw beheading people no
we're not we're not we're not causing
Global uh like violence we're not doing
that and and that's not the right answer
but I think because we're not doing what
other communities do maybe they're not
taking it as seriously I mean the fact
that President gay is still at Harvard
is mindboggling I was just going to ask
you how of every did everybody else get
kicked the MIT got
fired MIT MIT is pending they claim that
there's an internal review but nothing
else has been said probably everyone's
already said it just imagine she said
that calling genocide on black people is
okay imagine someone said that and they
stood by idly and allow that to happen I
wouldn't let that happen like nobody
should if you're a human being there are
there shouldn't be double standards but
with the Jews it's like yeah whatever
well and there's actually something good
coming at the end of this and it's
happening at at at Penn and Wharton
Wharton what most people don't know is
underneath the surface at Wharton it's
fairly moderate you know like one tick
over to conservative because that's the
way they feel about capitalism about
taxation well but it's a business school
but it also is an economic engine that's
paying a lot of bills for the rest of
the school Rob if you could go to dubdub
pen forward.com they apparently are up
to um 400 faculty that have signed this
pen forward this is a framework to guide
the university scroll up and let's just
read the first mission is keep going
keep going intellectual diversity civil
discourse political neutrality of the
administration institutional neutrality
and the university must remain neutral
to Scientific respect and tolerance for
who you are and then you go the bottom
and the number of people that have now
publicly signed this is massive it's
massive and this is employees tenured
professors and people at pen so this is
causing a good thing there's a ground
swelling of people that says we're not
afraid to speak up but we're not just
going to say oh you know you're liberal
you're crazy what they're saying is
here's the framework that we think
should embody an open neutral Center of
of of of um of education at higher
education and so they're putting this
forward and guess what the
administration is having a hard time
with this because the first shoe is
dropped they moved the president out yes
they moved her back to her uh her law
position but they moved the president
out and so I think this is actually a
good thing that's forcing them at the
administration level now will the change
come all the way down for students
everywhere and and Jewish students that
are sitting there saying my University
president doesn't believe that these
threats against me are are are bad am I
am I comfortable walking across the quad
without security at 9 :00 at night after
going to the research Library students
shouldn't be thinking about that but
those uh those University presidents
that were there did second point to your
question the price of free speech is pre
speech but the us civil code section
2101 which has been absolutely
unenforced and you can find literally a
thousand articles about this says that
inciting a riot is a crime it's a it's
the highest level misdemeanor crime in
other words almost a felony like
remember when they turn misdemeanors
into lowlevel felonies on Trump in New
York City yeah well this is the highest
level misdemeanor and it says acts of
organizing promoting encouraging or
participating in a riot advocating a
position or belief in speech or writing
without inciting violence is not a crime
so the price of free speech is Free
Speech you're going to hear things you
don't like but this you heard that mayor
Adams but this is that's right but this
has been completely unenforced and you
have lawyers and civil rights lawyers
liberal lawyers across the US saying you
know what cities are just choosing not
to enforce this because there is out
there Adam when you cross over and you
incite a riot the US criminal code
section 21101 is completely clear but it
said it's been horribly unenforced from
sea to shining sea and this is where you
can jump in about Soros funded District
Attorneys who just don't want to enforce
it and by the way you'd be right yeah
that's what he's doing te it up p no I'm
just saying sor that was actually very
good uh breakdown Tom on what you said
the question is if that's really out
there and lawyers know it why are they
why are lawyers not using this to hold
people accountable why property owner
lawyers are trying to Pat they're trying
to come to the DA and say these people
inited a riot and they destroyed my my
shop it's 5,000 deductible for me and my
insurance company's writing the check
how come it's not a story that we know
about how come it's not a story that's
being talked about why would why would
the mainstream media put the narrative
these people have the right to demon no
but Tom if let's just say a law let's
just say a group of lawyers are doing
this and they're making this public so
other people know about it that would be
something people on the other side would
be writing about so I don't think
they're doing enough for people to be
taking notice so if if you're a lawyer
and you know this exists and it's
happening in your city and if you're not
a lawyer go to lawyers and ask and say
what are we doing about this and and the
insurance companies writing checks where
are they well insurance companies are
worried about being cuz it does it takes
a position if they do go out there and
do that now you're defending uh a side
uh uh or you know or the other side but
okay so let me let me go to this next
story here that has to do with what
we're talking about briefly on Israel
Graham linding Graham says Israel will
have to accept two-state solution to
normalize ties in Arab countries um he
emphasized the necessity uh for Israel
to accept some form of two-state
solution to recognize Israel in order to
normalize ties with Saudi Arabia and
other Arab countries he also stressed
the importance of security buffers for
Israel stating Israel will demand
security buffers they've never demanded
before because they can't afford another
October 7th Graham Express support for
the Biden Administration
approach noting that they are trying to
revive the normalization efforts and I
think they're uh right to do so he
acknowledged the need for Israel to do
more to limit civil civilian debts while
highlighting the challenging situation
where schools hospitals are located
Graham warned that to address a
situation effectively would lead to
another generation of just tit for that
death Thoughts with all due respect
Graham um I cannot remind you enough how
many times Israel has tried to
compromise with the two State solution
so let me just read the facts CU I don't
speak on a motion 1936 appeal commission
Israel accepted Palestinians rejected
1947 un partition plan rejected and then
the Arab leagues waged a war the next
day that led to the alleged nakba of
displacement because they said get out
of here let's kill all the Jews and
you'll take the land back the next day
1967 cartoon resolution rejected by the
Palestinians 2000 Camp David Summit
Arafat and AUD Barack rejected by the
Palestinians 2005 we tried to compromise
Israel withdrew from Gaza could have
been the biggest beautiful Resort on the
beach and the best piece of land that
they had to offer instead they turned it
into a terrorism Haven 2008 HUD Meritt
offered a Palestinian State and it was
once again rejected and we've seen what
the Palestinian territories have turned
into so that is my reminder to you
secondly to address the civilians
horrible I've seen videos horrible from
October 7th I've seen videos of
casualties on the Palestinian side and
it's been very hard to sleep at night
seeing both but tell me what do you do
when nurseries and preschools and
hospitals are Hamas headquarters what do
you do in that instance do you Retreat
and be like well you know there's a lot
of people in there so let's just wait
till October 7th turns into December 7th
or January 7th what is the right thing
to do to like combat this and we've seen
enough proof it's not any more an
allegation we've seen the tunnels under
the hospitals we've seen literal Nursery
cribs that you lift it and there are
missiles being fired from under so
instead of putting pressure on Israel to
stop targeting civilians which they are
not doing why don't we globally put more
pressure which sounds like an oxymoron
because Kamas is a terrorist group but
put pressure on Kamas to stop using
civilian as human Shields you know
everyone's saying oh Israel needs to get
the hostages back noas needs to release
the hostages Israel needs to stop
targeting civilians Kamas needs to stop
using civilians as Shields they're
always looking at the wrong side of it
Israel's never to blame I'm sorry
Israel's been doing the most moral
things that I've ever seen I've never
seen an army release pamphlets
announcing when they're attacking I've
never seen that where was October 7th's
pamphlets hey we're about to rape your
family and burn you where was those
pamphlets but instead no Israel is the
bad guys and listen death is death and
it's horrible but all of the blame is to
be put on Hamas every single life that
has been taken is hamas's fault but the
but the response Emily like mind you I
was in the military power was in the
military and I I understand when
obviously Hamas horrible we need to get
rid of them that's that's a no-brainer
terrorist goodbye but the response would
well I think they're at 20,000 dead
right now
9,000 8,000 children the tactic of just
going in there bomb because the I think
it's entertainment unattainable goal to
be like we are not going to stop until
Hamas is dead how do you keep track
there's not a number they're not wearing
t-shirts that say terrorists how do you
and I get it it's freaking difficult but
like what's the number of civilians that
are going to die because if they could
tell us like a tally okay there's what
40,000 how many homas soldiers are there
40 who knows but there's there's no way
to know how many you're killing so my
thing is like is is it killing all like
we're not going to stop killing
everybody until we find every single
Hamas solders dead you can't you can't
get it you can't get that number and
those bombs don't affect the ones that
Israel is dropping they don't affect
tunnels I know they were talking about
filling the tunnels up with water at the
end of the day tactically you think
Hamas once they did October 7th they're
just hanging around in Gaza no the
majority of them are gone they all left
so it's like it's there's no winning in
this situation but it's and this is my
thing from the beginning it's the
children it's the N 8 to 9,000 children
and this is the misconception a lot of
people out there talk you can be
Pro Palestinian kids not dying and not
be a supporter of Hamas that drives
me bananas cuz I see people saying that
stuff if you care about the kids you
support Hamas there has to be a tactical
shift where it's not just bom bom bom
bom B bomb because we got to get rid of
Hamas that's my attitude I want to I
want to not combat that cuz what you
said is absolutely correct but there's
two sides this I don't want to start
playing whataboutism but can I just
point out how many Rockets a day are
sent to Israel where if Israel did not
have an Iron Dome our death count would
be a thousand times that every single
day I was just in Israel I got back last
night every single day running to the
bomb shelter every single day multiple
times a day imagine each of those
Rockets hit do you think they would do
it they would do it 10 times more if we
didn't have the iron doome so thank God
we have it our our death count by hour I
mean Israel is going to be 10 tenfold
what we just s for that and I'm not
justifying it it's wrong so I actually
would like to ask you guys what is the
right thing to do let Kamas be because
they're using civilians as human sh like
what is the right answer I don't have it
you don't have it no you made a very
eloquent list you talked about 1936 4767
2000 2005 2008 and you made a very
eloquent list there
and some of that is not visible to the
Casual citizen but most people know
about the 1967 war also known as The Six
Day War this was a coalition let's let's
just look at the accuracy of History
they're trying to negotiate Armistice
agreements and the Coalition of Arab
states engaged in a war against Israel
and what happened there was humiliating
to them Syria lost the goalen heights
the West Bank was lost by Jordan s the
entire Sinai P Peninsula was lost by
Nasser of Egypt and new borders were set
up and at the end of it Israel said the
new border is here and I don't trust you
so we need to also go back and look at
history and how the Coalition of Arab
states tried a a north east and west
pinch because they wanted to eradicate
the state and Israel armed with us
support us Weaponry which was Superior
as they found out to the Soviet crap
they they were using says that's what
happened at the end of it so if you want
to study history America go look at the
1967 war and look what happened there
and look what the result was the result
was you wanted to destroy me and
eliminate me but I pushed you back and
took some of your place we're now going
to call that like a buffer zone and that
is where listen to all those territories
the Golden Heights the West Bank Gaza
and Sinai those have been disputed areas
and areas of tension since
1967 let's remember what happened and
why the borders were changed I'd also
like to add to that that I don't even
think it's ever been about land I mean
1927 the Kevan massacres where 57 Jews
were slaughtered Israel was not even
established yet so you can't be like oh
well I want death to the zionists
because Zionism wasn't a thing at the
time so I think this just goes back to a
bigger problem than land I don't think
it's ever been about land it'll never be
about land I think the land is a means
to justify Jew hatred which is a very
unpopular opinion but if you look at
history that's what it shows you my
point there was a coalition here that
that was the end result land was taken
that was the end result but the point
was there was a coalition of Arab states
that wanted to pinch and eradicate
Israel period yeah and can I that's one
question while while armist agreements
were trying to be negotiated in bad
faith if you don't mind Pat cuz I want I
want to ask you you just got back from
Israel uh so it's been what 74 days
since the attack you know what I mean
the they came in they did their thing uh
we still haven't gotten any answers I
want to know if if if the is is are
Israelis talking about how I remember
John Kirby came out 5 days after the
attacks and they're like how could this
happened there and his answer was now is
not the time it's been 74 days we we
we're getting all these reports The Wall
Street Journal or the times reported
that Israel had a report called the
Jericho wall that was they found that
they knew it was going to happen a year
in advance I'm just wondering how
because obviously we don't want
something like that to happen again have
they strengthened have they figured out
are the people asking questions of how
something like this could happen and
meaning we don't want it to happen again
but how how how would this failure of
intelligence happen happened on 911
happened in Pearl Harbor what are we
doing to have it not happen again
because then when you ask questions
they're like now's not the time but 10
years down the road everything's said
and done then they're going to be like
oh yeah we effed up here we effed up
here and is anybody held accountable I
mean I think the answer is simple Israel
failed intelligence failed the Army was
negligent in a in a sense that I mean
from what I've heard not any official
reports is that they really undermined
and underestimated what Kamas was
capable of they thought they had it
under control and allegedly they had
these reports but they didn't have a
time and a date and they're like oh well
we have them we're good we have control
over Gaza and we know exactly what's
happening and no one's going to do this
to us and then when it happened in such
a high number of Hamas terrorists
infiltrating at once from different
directions I think the idef was so
overwhelmed and that's why the
casualties were Beyond something
Israel's ever seen so the short answer
is they failed as a country as a nation
as a government in every single sense
they failed and I will say that as the
biggest Zionist on the planet like they
messed up but the reality is this um if
a terrorist wants to attack no matter
how big or no how small the terrorism
Act is they're going to figure out way
whether they came in and they killed one
person on a kabut or whether they came
in and drove right they deal with that
every day this is literally what
terrorists do what's the what's the
definition of terrorism it is the
purposeful killing of innocent civilians
for political agenda
for any agenda and it's such a way to
create fear of other things happening so
what's my
point this is what they do they wake up
this is what they're planning for so
there was a there was a massive
intelligence failure ma massive
um army failure IDF everything you want
to go with that so for me it's not how
and why did this happen it
happened but here's the reality and like
we're going to see how this plays out
over the next several months there's
going to be people telling Israel go for
all kill them all there's going to be
people saying no more innocent lives I
get the entire argument if there's I've
been to Israel I've literally been
parting in Tel Aviv when I had to go
shelter and place in a bob shelter cuz
what what are these Sirens going off are
we in a club right now no there's
missiles coming from uh Syria right now
or Lebanon right now or uh Hamas right
now all right cool I guess I can't party
anymore cool because Tel Aviv if you've
never been there it's like if New York
and Miami and uh the Middle East had a
baby it's a great place awesome for me
it comes down to this where do we all go
from here after the dust settles
literally and the war is over what will
Hamas and Gaza do not even Hamas because
we've all recognized Hamas can no longer
be the leaders of uh the Palestinian
State whether it's fata or PA or whoever
comes in comes in there they're going to
be given a choice like they've been
given a choice multiple times before the
International Community the un uh Qatar
whoever ends up they're going to send
them what billions of dollars and they
have a choice Do you want to build
tunnel Sy systems of Terror or do you
want to be the next Dubai the choice is
yours if I'm me you know what Israel
wants they want them to be Dubai go be
the Dubai of the Mediterranean we wish
you luck we want GDP we want happiness
we want success we want much Nas for you
a trading partner we want we want
exactly and that you know who will
benefit from that the Palestinian people
the Israeli people but under Hamas rule
imagine being ruled by ISIS imagine
being ruled by al- Qaeda how's that
working out for the people in
Afghanistan being ruled for the Taliban
Jews actually empathize with what
they're going through they're
under Islamic militant command so much
so that the people that run the West
Bank the PA mmud Abbas they literally
can't even go into Gaza why you ask why
wouldn't the people that run the West
Bank the political organization PA why
can't they go to Gaza cuz Hamas would
kill them they've done it before once
they were elected in 2006 they were
throwing fata off the roofs so my wish
my prayer is that somehow some way the
gazin specifically the people of the
West Bank would say guys listen here's
the reality we've tried to overthrow
Israel and take the land River to the
Sea a dozen times I get bad news for you
guys they're not going anywhere where
are they going okay so let's try to
figure out a way for us to have success
but the problem is this in order to have
peace you need to have a peace partner
the the whole joke in Israel is Yo
Israel wants peace what does Hamas want
they want peace too the problem is they
want a piece of you over here and they
want a pece of you over there you can't
negotiate with terrorists we've heard
that a billion times how do you
negotiate with someone that literally
will not negotiate with you because in
their Charter the founding fathers of
Hamas the great leaders that they are
they want to exterminate all Jews how do
you negotiate with that well how do you
well how do you here's the thing how do
you you're never going to get rid of
Hamas and what's happening right now
they're multiplying all the 2 million
displaced and all the the 8 Milli 8,000
kids dead guess what the ones that are
surviving and leaving guess what they're
going to become the most Israel hating
people exactly perpetuating violence so
Vinnie you were in the Army Air Force
you're in the Air Force okay you were in
the Air Force yeah look give me a
military solution here go ahead you've
been in the military well first of all
Adam I want to just okay the horrible
situation we're just going to flatten it
and guess what even if you tell people
knocking on their door hey you guys have
to leave where are they going to go no
but but I'm asking I'm not even being
fous give me a military solution the
first I'm happy you said that the first
thing I would have done number one
secure Israel make sure whoever effed up
it doesn't happen again and I want
everybody accountable I don't give a
if it was Netanyahu who who is on
camera saying you know what we could do
whatever the hell we want want this is a
horrible look from we could do whatever
we want to Palestine America will
they'll just they'll just back us not
not a hold on not a good look number one
number one cck totally agree with you
number two number two not just
indiscriminately bomb the and
flatten Gaza and kick everybody out no
no no you don't do that you you get a
plan and you tactically go after these
you go in the tunnels you do
this you don't just ADAM Go bomb and
sorry you go in there you send Special
Forces you don't think the IDF and the
Israelis have
this isn't World War II this isn't World
War II or Vietnam where we just carpet
bomb I don't think the bombing is
indiscriminate no hold on hold on how
you know how many bombs they've dropped
on on God qu of bombs many bombs were
sent to is I I understand but guys
everything you're saying is correct but
what Emily just said is important do you
know that they're still shooting
missiles into Israel nobody's
complaining about the bombs that are
being dropped on Israel it's only the
bombs think think they're not carpet
bombing they have an agenda and they
have a schedule and I've never seen an
army that tweets what they're doing day
by day go to ID understand but but those
kids aren't reading tweets they're just
children that are like oh what
we're going to do and they're it's not
for the children it's for the world to
understand we're not carpet bombing Gaza
we're trying to race I'm not saying I'm
not saying carpet bombing but they're
bombing a lot have you guys se you said
indiscriminate and that I don't think
that's a fair representation I know
you're red up that part's not AES do you
know though you know where Hamas is
hiding they're the majority of these
guys are underground the bombs that
we're dropping on them guess what
they're not affecting these tunnels so
Adam my wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute I've seen I've seen very
detailed video of how they they launched
into tunnels the explosives and
everything and you can see the manhole
covers and the next levels you didn't
see you didn't see a bomb drop Tom
they're putting stuff inside the tunnel
to to blow the tunnels up but back back
to my point Adam you secure you said
they weren't affecting the tunnels and I
point out I said the bomb the bombs are
T that don't you're going in and putting
placing explosive in the tunnels to blow
those tunnels up that wasn't a missile
hitting a very effective Strat
okay I get back to my point my point is
you secure Israel so it never happens
again and there has to be a better
tactical plan Adam to go in and and find
Hamas which is I get it it's a freaking
difficult J so let me ask one more
question and then I'm sure Emily respond
everything he's saying is correct I
believe me I don't know one Jew that's
like let's kill them all zero you don't
think they could just kill 2 million
people okay whether the number is 10,000
20,000 whether it's Hamas it's hard to
distinguish because the un's getting
their numbers from
whoas so true by the way yeah so it's
like well let's just believe all these
numbers here but at the end of the day
let's say you're an innocent person in
in Gaza dude like what you think you
just want to hang out in your building
while it's about to get bombed you want
to get the out of there but what do
you do actually walk me through this
what do you do if Hamas says no no no
you're not going anywhere we'll kill you
if you leave because Hamas wants dead
people they want dead dead babies why
for propaganda that's how they get their
funding that's how they get their
empathy from around the world so Israel
whether you love Israel or hate Isel
it's irrelevant they're stuck in such a
tough place where they want to go after
terrorists they don't want to kill they
don't want to kill innocent people the
innocent people should be leaving
they've been warned Hamas will literally
kill their own people if they try to
leave so Israel's just like it's like a
a quandry and and a and a in a conundrum
a riddle and it's like it's so hard to
figure out and by the way that's a
metaphor for exactly what's happening in
this in this region for the last 75
years problem what you're saying you you
could kill people you can't kill an idea
he's saying this is a Band-Aid which is
absolutely correct the only solution to
this very very thin Band-Aid is
hopefully at least most of Kamas is
eradicated and I this I literally have
no clue how to go about we need somewhat
of a functioning government in Gaza it
can't be Isis orb or Hamas or P or all
the three initials that basically want
to just kill J well at the end of the
day the UN needs to come over un is
useless and at least they have an
International Community that will Le no
she's right I get about care but I'd
rather have the UN running Gaza than uh
Hamas the UN found un employees hiding
hostages in Gaza so they're part of the
terrorism problem too yeah I mean that's
a little extreme it's been shown they
were in un teachers homes being hidden
I'm not I'm not doubting that there's
some one-offs with that but but I would
rather have it internationally recogniz
organization running Gaza rather than a
terrorist organization say what you say
about the UN but at the end of the day
give me a plan give me a plan that says
this is how we'll have peace success GDP
for our people give me a plan because if
your plan is just from The River To The
Sea Palestine will be free that's not a
plan that's a call for genocide give me
a business plan we just did a whole BPW
business planning workshop for your plan
planning your next five moves if your
next five moves is just continuing war
and terrorism and destruction and
genocide that's not a game plan for
Success that the International Community
will basically get behind show me a plan
yeah Adam show me a plan how peace
success I get but you know and you
nailed it you know why it's so freaking
hard because if the goal is to eradicate
Hamas there's no way of actually going
okay they're done like with Isis we
destroyed Isis we destroyed Isis we
can't that's why this is such a shitty
situation because you're like there's
not a checklist okay Hamas is gone then
so I think the short answer is none of
us have the answer so isn't it crazy
tell country what to do after they fac
their 911 no doubt I I would say one
thing and we can wrap up go to the next
one to go to the next story I'm enjoying
this conversation listen to you guys I
think the one thing is uh that we're
seeing specifically last three years is
when America is weak people get
exploited they get taken advantage of
and one of the things we're not talking
about is is is a the the benefits of a
strong leader running America that gets
involved and puts the fear of death upon
everybody and says hey we're not doing
this you want to do this we're going to
destroy XYZ and if you cross this line
here's what's going to happen and we're
going to bring the right kind of support
not the wishy-washy support the support
that Bon gave was never real real
support it was kind of like well and
this and that and this it was kind of
like worried about election like am I
going to get reelected of a decision he
was making rather than no here's what
we're going to do whether you like it or
not you cross the line This is not
something that we're going to support
and accept we're doing this to you
there's no fear like that coming from
America if this was any other situation
you can even go to George Bush if this
was any other situation the fear of
death was put on the people to say you
cannot cross the line and there's been
no feeling like that from America at all
zero so there's nobody that fears
anybody and Bully sitner saying this is
awesome you freaking kidding me it's
open game let me go take whatever I want
and they're doing what they're doing
let's transition to the next story I got
10 more stories I want to go through
okay so next one which has to do with
this and that's the hoties okay what
happened with the hoties so I want to I
want to show this on a couple things
that's going on right now because this
everybody is feeling uh economically
you're about to feel it again so hoties
who are I want to say west of Yemen
right on the Red Sea where 10% of oil
goes through okay where 12% of all
everything we buy goes through where 30%
of shipping containers goes through the
Red Sea the canal that they all go
through they attack this ship I believe
it's called the Galaxy leader Rob if you
got the video of how they take over the
ship and then all of a sudden you know
what they're doing they're dancing
they're celebrating uh you can just play
the clip you know just press play and
real quick P they're funded and backed
by Ira Rebel audio yeah look at this
this theot foot AG they're just getting
there they're funded by Iran that's
right so they're like little Pirates now
they're little Pirates now with a
helicopter so not just any kind of
pirates they show up you can fast
forward a little bit yeah look at that
boom Oh my God yeah they land they land
on they land they got a camera guy they
got editor they run around look at this
they run around and then they're dancing
at the end it looks like a video like
and they took over to Captain look at
this this just by
this just happened a few weeks ago and
in FYI while this is going on Rob if you
can pull up the F which is kind of weird
you know how much money goes through the
Red Sea how much money like how much of
the world GDP is affected by the red
sea1 trillion a trillion dollar a year
is going through there okay so it's not
like a small little thing that we're not
going to feel if this thing so now what
they're doing is rather than going
through the Red Sea they have to go all
the way around so it's roughly between
7,000 miles to say you know 13,000 miles
so imagine the number of risks you have
going this way red SE is a little bit
less choppy there you go 12% of global
trade 30% of all the global containers
and 10% of oil goes through here now W
in the last two to four weeks Rob can
you pull up the number type in um US
military 78 attack CBS just type
everything like that and pull it up it's
got to be the first story look at this
here right there at the top right there
at
the tax um so there's been 78 attacks on
us the
last go up a little bit see if it shows
been three months I this was okay this
is this was pre- Thanksgiving Pat this
is type in let me zoom in a little bit
on what you put all the way at the top
US Destroyer US military uh uh 78
attacks military base I'll find a link
for you and send it to you and you never
hear it huh they've attacked our bases
78 times has been attacked and we have
not right there right there second uh
second the top paragraph Iran back
militias in Iraq have claimed
responsibility for dozens of attacks
that Target a bases housing US troops in
Iraq and Syria since Israel declared war
on Hamas two months ago the US military
says 78 attacks have been carried out
against us facilities over the past few
weeks of which 37 were Iraq 41 is in
Syria what are we doing about
retaliation what we doing about to me
that's the all of this is a byproduct of
a weak leader lacking somebody at the
top that puts the fear of death into
these people so they're taking advantage
of what do you mean you attacked our
base 78 times what do you mean you think
you can get away with this thing who do
you think you are and we're just sitting
on the sidelines accepting this so I
have a problem with the our leadership
team on how they're responding to it
laxidasical
casual uh not being assertive about it
and the hoties are sitting there saying
this is a great opportunity for us go
ahead Tom wow you know what really
interesting um you go back about 5 years
ago let's think who was president 5
years ago do you remember the Somali
pirates that were jumping on containers
yeah that's what it just reminded me the
Somali pirates were Somalia is like a
failed nation state they were supported
by Yemen directly in the houthis and
they were getting their arms from the
supporter of Yemen which is Iran Iran so
there was a whole um what do they call
that supply chain that went back to Iran
that was the Somali pirates what
happened was you the US was like well
you're in international waters wait a
minute if I'm in international waters
can I hire retired uh military guys to
be the security force similar to we had
the Air Marshals on airplanes they were
plane closed you didn't know who they
were but they were there and so they put
these guys on there Captain Phillips was
a movie and everything and guess what it
stopped because they got 50 caliber and
they've got big guns and they've got
military trained retired military guys
that are operating independent Security
Forces with the support of a US
president Pat and guess what happened
when you change Actuarial tables for
your career as a Somali pirate and you
bring it out like really shorten those
Actuarial tables people Insurance know
what I'm talking about um guess what
that's a deterrent the best thing and it
goes right back to what you're saying
Pat the best thing for the world is a
strong US president that the rest that
the Bad actors in the world think is
crazy let me say that again the best
thing for the world is where they think
are the bad s think our president is a
little crazy they thought Reagan was
crazy they thought Trump was crazy
because deterrence is a stabilizing
Force going back to my dad because my
brother and I had a peacekeeping
agreement because if my dad got home
that was deterrence and now just think
of that on a world stage a crazy us when
I hear Iran saying oh president Trump is
crazy I'm like I go to bed you know what
I sleep well that night I want to say
that he is yeah yeah good to be loved or
test him walk across the line mother
test him that's the three qualities of a
great leader loved respected feared okay
and when you're a leader of a country as
big as ours we a leader of the Free
World guess what matters the most fear
then respected then love if you love me
cool if you don't I don't care I don't
really care but I want you to fear and
respect we don't have that today so this
account and by the way let me read this
what the htis aim to do they aim to
govern all of Yen and support external
movements against us Israel Saudi Arabia
they have launched repeated missile and
drone attacks against a number of Saudi
cities they hate Saudi they hate us they
hate Israel they are allies with Iran
North Korea these are their allies who
they're allly and by the way they're big
they're they're five times the size of
Hamas just so you know and they're
bigger than Hezbollah this is not a
small organization this is not a small
everybody talks about Hezbollah and
Yemen and all and Hezbollah and Hamas
houis are massive powerful big budget
trained and they're formidable so you
have to understand what they're doing
right now is they're saying oh you and
by the way you know what their leader
said let me let me tell you what the
leader the the major general of their
military said here's what he said check
this out that's pretty powerful war on
Gaza uh ysep Al madani a major general
any escalation in Gaza is an escalation
in the Red Sea and any come in Gaza is
considered a come in Red Sea so gu what
guess what they're saying you want to
attack Gaza you're going to fill it with
your pocketbooks do you know how many
ships and how many companies are no long
six of the largest shipping companies
oil companies are no longer sending
their ships through there they've halted
all of it six of the BP number one
they're no longer going through there
here's what else he said he said any
country or party that comes between us
and Palestine we will confront it htis
are not Hamas if you think Hamas is
annoying wait till you de deal with
these guys well so why won't they take
all the Palestinian refugees if they're
such good allies be it's a well I mean
that's the conversation with Egypt
you're going to go to Jordan that's the
same conversation a lot of people are
having but uh yeah so they're they're
coming from that standpoint with what
they're doing but I have a question for
you just back to that video and and this
is a dumb question I'm going to fully
acknowledge that if you're trying to you
know ship your product across the sea
and on a big ship do they have like
missiles or anything on the ship for
protection like if you see an
unidentified helicopter approaching your
ship you can't shoot it down some of
these some of these ships hire like
exmilitary guys I've seen videos of like
especially the ones like the captain
Philips type thing where they literally
are exmilitary arm with M16s and they're
brutal videos and they shoot them dead
so my question is why didn't they do
that I see and I I just think some of
these ships like and some of these ships
do if You' seen the movie Captain
Phillips they have this water spray to
deter them when it's when it's like this
yeah but guns the's not doing much they
have to be I mean you have to pay to
have security but so depending on what
the cargo is they they normally don't
have this type of security unless it's
something that they don't want to lose
because they will shoot your ass de the
ship they took over Galaxy theer is a
massive ship by the way you know who
owns Galaxy leader go type in who owns
Galaxy leader I believe it's called race
shipping owned by a Jewish owner uh
there it is race shipping company owned
by Israeli businessman Ramy unar oh so
there's and this is a ship that was from
Poland but it's owned by race shipping
they're targeting so it's not like it's
a small ship and she's making a very
good point why don't you protect the
ship right why don't you have certain
you know military personnel to protect
the ship some carriers do I want to give
a little perspective because it's
interesting you said that the houthis
who are basically the iran-backed
militia you said they're bigger than
Hamas and and all that yeah wow so
people don't know this but they should
that arguably the greatest humanitarian
crisis that's been going on in the past
five plus years has been in Yemen where
there's a uh proxy war between Iran and
Saudi Arabia so it was interesting that
Pat said the houis aim their goal I
don't know if this has ever been said
before is to bring down the US Israel
and Saudi Arabia okay interesting Saudi
Arabia what what are we talking about
the interesting one that's the
interesting part there we we have all
heard Iranian what's going on in
theocracy in in in Iran about death to
America death to Israel death to
basically the modern Western world but
the the Saudi Arabia thing is
interesting why because during the
Abraham Accords under Trump and most
recently under uh somewhat continuation
over Biden they've been trying to make
peace Israel has made diplomatic efforts
to make peace all around the Middle East
so Netanyahu whether you like him or
don't like him the reality is he's
basically said I'm doing the 99% versus
1% strategy what's that rather than
trying to make peace with the 1% over
here people in Gaza Hamas not happening
let me go out and try to make peace with
the Muslim world and he has done that
okay everything with the Abraham Accords
where they've made pieces peace deals
with the UAE and byin and Oman and
obviously the Jordan and and Egypt uh
but the next on the list people forget
this prior to October 7th they were this
close with having a peace agreement with
Saudi who's running Saudi these days
really the face of Saudi is NBA Muhammad
Bel Salman who's bringing Saudi Arabia
into modernity he's basically saying if
we want to actually have a country with
success and GDP and and um profits for
our country let's let me sort of engage
in the international rules-based order
and actually be a part of the rest of
the world and they've had they've done
that with a lot of success that's why
you see them buying sports teams and the
live golf stuff and they're basically
saying listen you know if you can't beat
them join them let's join the rest of
the world I'd love to see that of course
and that's what's happening in exactly
and basically that's isolating Iran even
further so this proxy war in Yemen
has killed hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people in Yemen but you
don't hear the Hamas the Gaza gig
Brigade marching about what's going on
in in in Yemen there's millions of your
fellow Arabs Muslims dying Afghanistan
Syria Afghanistan and Syria and Lebanon
like but they're they're singularly
pointing out what's going on to 10,000
or so people in Palestine but at the end
of the day you have to figure out this
we talked about this um International
rules based order it's all about
alignment who's aligned on one side you
have China Russia North Korea and who
Iran Iran's funding the houti rebels
they're funding Hamas they're funding
Hezbollah they're funding anything that
starts with an H that promotes terrorism
um on the other side you have whether
you like them or not and this is the
team that I'm on United States the EU
Israel Canada Australia Japan
democracies at the end of the day it
comes down to one thing democracies
versus autocracies and autocracies and
dictators and theocrats they're aligning
and you have people that are the liberal
Democratic countries that are coming
together saying n this is how we want to
operate and this is how I want toate so
it's really a clash of cultures East
versus West and you know shout out to
Muhammad B Solomon I mean I'm not not
not a fan of him choing upam alikum my
friend by the way by the way I know what
you're saying but but the key out of all
those countries Saudi plays a very
important role because Saudi has
typically played you know Switzerland
and they've kind of been like trying to
please everybody there he's taking a
stand to say look man we got to bring
peace to the Middle East because if we
want to compete with all these other
countries and we want to bring soccer
golf all this stuff here he's going to
play a very important role us announces
10 Nation Force to counter hooti attack
in Red Sea this just came out last night
uh says Coalition will include Bahrain
Canada France Italy UK and other countes
so we'll see what's going to happen
there but I do believe the best part of
that news is NBS wants to bring economy
he wants to bring Commerce he wants to
bring celebrities he wants to bring
shows to Saudi that benefit he's a
genius he is a genius he's going to have
to figure out a he had a little bit of a
hiccup but he's got to bring some people
over Pat how would you how would you
this is an interesting question but you
grew up in Iran obviously you're a big
fan of the Sha right um you interviewed
his son most recently
Iran people don't know this it was like
the Paris of the Middle East in the the
60s the 70s all that before um it was
taken over in 79 Revolution how would
you compare what MBs is doing trying to
take this islamist country that is you
know uh been sort of radicalized
radicalized you know kind of tiptoeing
around terrorism for quite some time and
trying to bring it into modernity and
trying to bring it into the rest of the
world and have success how's that what
correlation do you even see with the sh
Iran and NBS today a lot the difference
is you know like the Iran you know had a
different kind of resources some similar
but uh yeah they have a lot of
similarities uh this guy is very
ambitious he is extremely ambitious with
what he wants to make that place be and
I think the best part is like when
you're talking about why don't you make
Palestine into the Dubai who would
benefit from it everybody benefits from
it but there's a community that doesn't
want that Adam when we lived in Iran for
10 years they would say mad bad amria
death upon America be careful they're
going to make your daughters into the
Western girls be careful they're going
to turn your they would they would put
the fear of their girls becoming
is how they would sell it literally they
would say if you Embrace Western Society
you couldn't watch movies in Iran from
us it was all underground we had to all
go there would be a guy that would be
underground selling VHS to other people
because they didn't want you to get any
of the Western culture in they don't
look at what we live as our lifestyle as
the way to live they fear that all day
long Saudi is trying to say hey man some
of the stuff we're doing here we got to
get away from it he's called out his own
people religious leaders and they've not
like NBS a lot when he did that so again
he has some issues with him with the
journalist you know when that took place
a couple years ago where I give him some
controversy a guy was challenging
pushing him but I think all in all it's
going in the right direction he's one of
the key leaders that's going to help
bring peace to that area I think what we
have to take a look at is um George W
bush and Trump both had a lot to do with
what's emerging with NBS and just go
back and look at the age of the
gentleman as he's come to power to be a
successor Prince and now run it there
are three words that MBS hates and it is
these drill baby drill when the US is
Drilling and we are energy independent
and we are exporting excess natural gas
he loses his chairmanship over OPEC when
when Venezuela basically collapses and
is no longer part of um the key Supply
volumes they're still exporting oil but
they're not part of the key that hurts
OPEC so what he is doing is he is
elevating Saudi Arabia while carefully
if you go in by the way you go down
there you it's not spring break you're
not going to go party there and your
sister is not going to be running on the
beach with a bikini trust me he is
trying to bring them forward as a
trading and economic partner with the
west and a lot of people saying well
he's doing it with Sport washing that
they call it buy I'll take it right but
he's bringing stability to it and every
time we're more energy independent we're
actually causing him to be a stabilizing
force in the Middle East because he
wants to be that stabilizing force and
he wants to have economic integration
because he doesn't want war he wants
wealth and so let me tell you every time
a US President says drill baby drill
we're going to be energy independent
we're going to be an exporter guess what
it creates a tension and he is reacting
in this way and as far as the houthis I
wish they would just you know take over
the Yemen newspaper print some bad
articles about Saudi and this thing will
be over in an afternoon I like what you
said right there that he doesn't want
war he wants wealth and I wish I wish
that for the people of Gaza oh no Hamas
has wealth but the people are literally
starving stre but the people have have
no money that's what saud's doing right
but but the the the top of the Hamas
food chain they're living in they're
literally flying around in private jets
they're billionaires allegedly they've
taken all that money they ransacked it
for themselves they're living in Qatar
they're living in in Lebanon they're
living a good life but the people in
Gaza are suffering I wish that that
money funnel to the people even a little
bit of it that's a lot of money can we
go into the the Trump uh please story
let's go into the Trump story Rob I I I
just sent you something I don't know if
you're able to show that on the big
screen or not um it's a dedication to
Tom if you're able to pull that up Kanye
thing right there it's something I'm
miss the old Kanye yeah let's let's go
through the story here all right Donald
Trump banned from Colorado ballot in
historic ruling by state supreme court
the Colorado Supreme Court and a
landmark decision declared that Trump is
disqualified from holding the office of
president under section three of the
14th Amendment marking the first ever
use of this provision to disqualify a
president candidate the ruling was made
in a 4-3 decision by the courts justices
all of whom were appointed by the democ
by Democratic Governors the court
overturned a district court judges
ruling that Trump incited an
Insurrection but questioned whether the
provision applied to the presidency
however the Colorado Supreme Court
disagreed stating that President Trump
asks us to hold that section three
disqualifies every oath breaking
insurrectionist except the most powerful
one and that is bars oath Breakers from
virtually every office both state and
federal except the highest one in the
land uh Emily thoughts on this quite
simple you don't have to like Trump to
acknowledge how scary this is I don't
like your opinion so I'm going to do
everything in my power to censor you do
you see the slippery it's the
slipperiest slope possible it's like now
because you don't like what this guy has
to say this guy meaning our former
president potentially could be our
future president so we're just going to
start you know manipulating laws and
amendments and try to find a way to keep
him out of power even though if he's so
bad for the country don't worry CU
people won't vote for him so it's like
whether he wins or loses let it be fair
don't don't let him lose because you
guys cheated within our own country it's
just it's scary it's Trump today it's
going to be someone else tomorrow then
there's no line between who we censoring
and who are preventing from potentially
being our President it's horrific and
you know I think too it's like and I
know a lot of people are upset yesterday
when I saw this I I was tripping out I
texted everybody they should be but you
know what you know what you have to do
you have to tip your hats to the
Democrats I mean these guys and girls
play to win and let let me just break it
down really fast they tried cheating in
2016 with Russian collusion right
Hillary DNC FBI and for four years we
had to hear their it didn't
stick so they cheated again in 2020 they
Ed covid uh to make people vote from
home then they have the FBI at Twitter
81 of them suppressing stories Hunter
Biden Joe Biden his his business
dealings with China Ukraine then this is
brilliant January 6 happens they know
it's going to happen the chief of police
Steven Sun said I we had death threats
we knew it was going to be bad they
ignored all of it including Pelosi and
Schumer they let hit the fan they
had uh Capitol Police shooting rubber
bullets they made this violence happen
and then they went after everybody and
they're using against Trump Pat say what
you want about these guys they don't
play they they go for it you got to tip
your hat off to them imagine they put
this much effort into actually fixing
the country exact they don't have time
for that they just want the power this
this thing is hanging by a thread um let
me tell you something about the Colorado
state supreme court Colorado state
supreme court is one of the liberal and
politicized state Supreme Courts in the
nation and yet they were only able to
squeak out a 43 decision this is not 62
ex me that's nine so this is the on uh
61 it's not 61 this not 52 This is 43
they were barely able to get themselves
to the edge to do this number one this
number two that doesn't cover them but
they're but they have alignment with the
ninth Circus the ninth circuit is known
as the ninth circus it is the most
overturned um uh appell at court in the
United States it's based in California
but it covers the entire West Coast and
not Colorado but there's alignment
between them the key player in all this
is the United States solicitor general
who is going to hear this in short order
and determine whether the Supremes take
it up and I don't believe that this was
anything other than the Democratic party
working with Colorado Supreme and trying
to get this over the edge to get it
quote out there I believe that's what's
happening here and I believe if this
goes to US Supreme it d
six it it
dies by a wider margin by the way fully
agree with you Tom at the end of the day
this is going to go to the Supreme Court
where well there's a what a 63
Republican majority over there I mean
this look whether you're a fan of trump
or not a fan of trump at the end of the
day this should be sort of uh shocking
to see that you can eliminate someone
from a ballot by the way this affects
the primary which I think in Colorado is
in March I want to say so at that point
Yeah March 5th I want to say so at that
point they're already they're already
going to have Iowa they're are going to
have New Hampshire they're going to have
I think a ton of States vote March 5th
but look I'm not happy to see this you
know I'm not the biggest fan of trump
but I do believe that he should be at
least qualified to run for election um
and um not a fan of what's going on here
and and any all my Democratic friends
out there whether you hate Trump want to
see Trump is you he hasn't been found
guilty of anything yet in the federal
court this called cheating yeah actively
but now like Democrats are like how why
I don't understand what's this is why
when Republicans say this is election
interference it's like kind of sees that
way I love this can I can I ask you a
question I know I have a friend and I
don't know if you know this or not I
have a friend named Patrick M David he
wrote a book called choose your enemies
wisely I just almost finished reading it
yeah pretty good book I want to ask you
a question do you think that Trump chose
his enemies wisely in the sense of
Patrick the doj FBI when he came on said
I'm going to drain the swamp and what
another do you think that was a wise
choice meting he just had to do it to do
it to wake everybody up or cuz it's
backfiring right now what do you think I
I I think this is fantastic because
there are certain enemies you don't make
it this obvious that you're willing to
get this dirty to do it and Democrats
are saying we're willing to do anything
and everything to prevent this guy from
running it shows insecurity it shows
fears it shows lack of confidence it
shows gamesmanship it it shows so many
different things you don't have to be a
fan of this guy to you can hate Trump
and say dude this is a little bit uh
weird by the way uh to know this this
isn't the first time you know this has
happened in 1860 when Lincoln was
running he was running against the
Democrat and guess what happened in 1860
10 states Lincoln wasn't on The Ballad
on 10 states who were pro-slavery States
they were afraid of what Lincoln was
going to do the Democrats in 1860 were
like oh if this guy wins do you re
go ahead and open this and read this up
open it up if you can just zoom in a
little bit Rob 1860 us election uh on
Tuesday in a four-way contest Republican
ticket Abraham lincol and Hannibal
Hamlin absent from the ballot in 10
slave states 10 slave states so I can't
win a state slave state blue state slave
state you know what I'm saying slave
state One a't National popular and then
next thing you know they end up
destroying the entire thing becoming
president look what the scor ends up
being 30 303 to what 152 can you go a
little bit to the right Rob 303 members
of 152 82% they end up winning they are
so scared of something like this
happening they are fearing the results
of what could potentially end up taking
place here so you think he chosen what
so you think he chose wi I don't know
what they're doing I I you know from the
standpoint of when you're trying to beat
somebody when you're willing to cheat to
beat them you're showing the public your
cards too much but it's like they're not
embarrassed of they're not hiding it
from anybody but but this is in no
Playbook is this a good strategy exactly
I want to see this at the Supreme Court
because it this decision will Corner
Kagan and sodomy because they are very
big on voting rights and liberal broad
access to vote they are huge on it and
it will force those two women to if you
want to they may say well I'll vote no
because it's going to pass 63 anyway
because of you know Comey Bryant and and
and everybody else that's there and and
you know the Supreme Court John Roberts
is going to carry it I want to see how
they vote on it because Kagan in
particular is very concerned she always
has been about
retaliatory the Justice the you know the
um retaliatory Justice she's very
concerned about that she was really
revved up about that on the uh the roie
Wade decision that came out I want to
see it get to The Supremes because I I
bet that America will be surprised at
what they see the vot I think they're
doing is they're just strengthening
Trump the other side I agree but is it
but is it tactic but do you think moves
Pat there's a bigger game that gets
played you think that that you think
that that's their tactic though CU they
have something bigger up their sleeve I
don't try they're they're Relentless bro
they don't stop at anything you know
would be super interesting what because
even if he's not on the ballot which I
believe he will be because I believe the
Supreme Court will overturn this but
let's just play this game goad how crazy
would it be if he's left off the ballot
and there'd be there'd have to be some
Grassroots campaign
but he wins by WR in votes mean you go
to vote the primary all I got christe I
got Haley I got my guyc my guy got the
Santa I'm just gonna write in Trump
imagine if oh wow that they just wrote
in Trump har he could do it yeah exactly
right so just I mean don't rule that out
like sound like he doesn't have name
recognition in Colorado yeah we're
entering into the Absurd a long long
time ago there was a movie where was it
Richard prior he ran as the candidate
and he named himself none of the above
so funny Tom can you pull up that clip
VC said this yesterday by the way this
this thing went viral and that's a bad
picture of
him this thing went viral yeah I will
viral yesterday but watch what we got to
say go ahead they have just tried to Bar
president Trump from the Colorado ballot
using an unconstitutional maneuver that
is a bastardization of the 14th
Amendment to our US Constitution this
was a provision section three that was
designed to Bar Confederate members
people switch to the Confederacy from
actually being able to serve that's very
different than what's at issue here to
say the least this is a hollowed out
husk of what the country was built on
the basic principle that we the people
select our leadership not the unelected
elite class in the back of Palace Halls
that's Old World Europe not the United
States that's why I'm making a pledge
today that I will withdraw I pledge to
withdraw from the col ad GOP Primary
ballot unless and until TR Trump's name
is
restored and I demand that Ronda sis and
Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do the
same thing or else these Republicans are
simply complicit in this
unconstitutional attack on the way we
conduct our constitutional republic I
refuse to be complicit in that I think
what they're doing is wrong and I think
it's up to Republicans to step up and
stand up with a spine for our country's
future that's really what's at stake
whether we the people actually have a
say in deciding who leads this country
yes it would be easier for other
Republicans like me who are running in
this race to say hey if Trump is
sideline there's our opportunity no
doubt other candidates are probably
privately celebrating with their
corporate sponsors that's not the right
thing to do I think the most useful
thing that every GOP candidate can do
right now is to join me in that pledge
I'll say that I will withdraw from that
Colorado primary ballot until Trump Ser
belongs to the people not to the unelect
Dem of
Judges
Oris do the same thing or else they're
complicit in what the security state is
trying to do to shut down Trump so right
I stand by that I expect he's like if I
win I'm whatever he's like if I win I'm
going to do fair and square not because
the Democrats are cheating by trying to
sideline Trump and I honestly think it's
commendable he's such you know if I was
on the other side I'd be very very
concerned listening to the next Attorney
General of the United States talking
like that you thinking he could be I
would if I was Trump and I was elected
and I don't think he really would want a
vice president role I would make him Ag
and I would just say don't even come to
my desk I just want to see on the news
every night I just want to see per walks
I want to see per walks top to bottom I
want you to be my AG I want you to be
the AG from hell they would fear the
hell out of the sky no doubt I I don't I
don't think that VC is going to want the
VP job but I do think he'd make a hell
of an attorney general I think he'd make
it a hell of a chief of staff itial
National Security advisor you can put
him at the Secretary of the Treasury you
can put him Secretary of State any job
he wants like I don't think he's doing
this to co up to Trump I actually firmly
believes that he believes that we spent
enough time with VC to know what he
stands for what are the chances that
Secretary of State yeah Tom come on
people people are talking buddy um when
um what are the chances that Ding
what are the chances that um Chris
Christie withdraws from the ballot hell
no uh what are the chances that Ronda
santz does it what are the chances that
hungry no go
Tom the reality is he's one step ahead
of all these guys and you're looking at
what I think is the future of the
Republican party after whatever happens
with Trump in
2028 just to to bring it back to the
other side I want to broaden this for a
minute people need to start condemning
when wrong is wrong and this goes just
beyond election fraud like today it's
the the Republicans being wronged
tomorrow's the Democrats and I always
say this about like the Holocaust like
the fact that people are like oh
whatever about it like no it was the
Jews then so even if you hate Jews you
should care because it could have been
Muslims or Christians I mean look at the
orar being killed and and genocide in
China that nobody's talking about like
one day it's this person the next day
it's that wrong is wrong common
denominator so any normal rational
person which we lack today should fear
that but they don't and that's a problem
all right let's go to the next one here
next story is um where is this hary Den
story I want to find this uh okay can we
can go to us Economist predicts 2024
will bring biggest crash of our lifetime
P six Tom that wasn't this year uh no
saying 2024 okay Economist Harry D
predicts a significant market crash in
2024 due to overvalued markets and
excessive stimulus spending stating I
think 2024 is going to be the biggest
single crash we'll ever see in our
lifetime D believes that the current
market itions constitute an everything
an everything bubble that began in late
2021 and Wars of a ready
86% crash 86% crash in the S&P 500 92%
in NASDAQ and a 96% in crypto he also
project a 50% crash in the average house
price which will hit people the hardest
Dent advises investors to be cautious
and Get Out The Way of the impending
crisis suggesting that they can
potentially reinvest at lower prices and
magnify their gains Mr Ells word can can
you break that down for idiots yeah so
he's listen 86% crash in S&P 500 do you
know what that means I mean that's
that's worse than the Great Recession
that's worse than Co that's great than
the Great Depression it's it's oh it's
the streets are people robing and it's
it's layoffs it's a show so Tom
what do you think about this 86 fear
porn he's selling us so fear porn is
right I mean God bless you Harry Dent
but you're out there just trying to
scare people in 2009 you wrote the book
The Great Depression ahead and a lot of
that didn't come true you know when it
comes to fear porn you are like PornHub
for the economics people that want to
freak people out it can't you come on
you Harry you have an economic interest
in selling books especially your next
book and the subscribers to your
newsletter I wish he would stay
with his slightly bearish point of views
which have been heralded as being not
soothsaying the future but prudently
looking at the future but right now he's
grabbing headlines on a slow news day
we're a ways from getting quarterly
reports the FED is kind of in its
doghouse and just kind of waiting for
things nothing big to see here and it's
and we've had our Black Friday news so I
was looking at this looking at the
timing of it most Financial people and
Adam you know you know the voices that
are in finance they kind of pick their
spots when they come up like Groundhog
Day pop up and say things and I think
Harry Dent is doing it right here and I
think there's there's 80% po you know
fear porn in here and 20% hey is this a
time to prudently look at 2024 maybe it
is I I'm not particularly worried about
24 not as I was three months ago dude
I'm so sick of like this I got to
tell you I mean we've covered this
before I mean and as much as I love and
respect kiaki he calls for this every
year there's a bunch of people that do
this this is Doom and Gloom of the
highest proportion 92% 88% this is the
Great Stop depression recession all
mingle co-mingled into one but here's
what I want we talk about accountability
all right where's accountability with
China what's going on with Co what's
going on accountability election
denialism what's going on to January 6th
all right let's see what happens in 2024
if the market stays the same little flat
goes up I'd like you to resign from your
position never write another Doom and
Gloom prognosticator because this is
shocking and sends shock wave throughout
the economic world it's so ridiculous
it's so ridiculous it's it's
mathematically impossible if you just
think of asset value of raw materials by
way but this guy's not dumb he's not
dumb he's not a dummy to say something
like that no I that's why I say
groundhog Dave Pat because the groundhog
pops out of there and there's a big
commotion what's the song in the movie
Groundhog Day what's the song Every
Morning in Groundhog they would build
get your little share
Bono I got you these are by the way
these are the books he booked he read
what a what an the Great
Depression ahead
and dude the guy's an like what
are you doing bro people are scared of
reading this but you know what it
is it's like the guy on uh you know ESPN
game day or NFL live and he's like you
know uh the Buffalo Bills are going to
blow out the Cowboys this week no the
Cowboys are going to beat the of
mark my words the Cowboys are going to
crush the bills this week and final
score uh Buffalo Bills 31 uh Dallas
Cowboy where you at that hos I think I
say every year the Knicks are going to
the finals so this but Adam this is
accountability this is a guy saying the
Kansas City an analyst are going to go 0
and 17 next year exactly he's talking
like the the the I understand that
something could happen next year don't
get me wrong next year it's a little
weird year I mean it's too many weird
things are happening with even if they
like the story goes into why they have
to lower the rates you see how they're
going to have to low the race to prevent
from a what pages the story time that
says okay here we go fed official says
rate Cuts could be needed next year to
prevent overtightening okay I get that
that we may need to do that to prevent
overtightening San Francisco fed
president Mary daily supports
considering interest rates in 2020 L
anticipate at least three rate cuts and
next year she states we're acknowledging
progress when progress is there daily
emphasizes the importance of avoiding
overly restrictive monetary policy and
its potential impact on job stability
she watches for signs that the labor
market is weakening and highlights the
need to balance inflation employment
concerns she stresses the goal of
achieving both price stability and labor
market stability recent government data
indicates that mild inflation in
November with core inflation potential
dipping below 2% on 6month okay yes I
agree with that by the way she % first
of all why would you even write that
article I mean go ahead Tom go ahead no
no no and I was saying the reason she
uses the word could is because she's one
of the FED Board of Governors Jerome
Powell is the spokesman so all she says
is could and then she quotes Powell for
a paragraph because she's not authorized
to be you know what I'm saying she's not
authorized to P say the one this is
going to be our policy do 86% Pat to
your point yeah what I do in moments
like this is all right when did his most
recent book come out no but I don't
probo some s of book what's his
background economics he's somebody in
economics like he's a guy that's been
around he's a New York Times bestseller
zoom in Rob everyone's a New York Times
bestseller not everyone this guy's not a
zoom in a little bit he sold books but
so he hasn't but besides the books he
has an economic background of some sort
yeah he's an economist yeah he's an can
you go to his I what an econic
background is go to his Wikipedia so we
can see what his wife must be like all
right he's 70 years old he's been saying
stuff like to zoom in okay where
is dentist found
investment P he has written 11 books two
recent ones best sellers the sale
lifetime
B the consumer okay um P I'm sure people
who are listening on audio really
appreciating
this totally what it is with this guys
all right let's go to the next St let's
talk about something that really matters
okay some serious uh uh stories here um
this may be the most important story we
have here Southwest has given free extra
seats to obese people I identify as
obese what is more important than this
think about it what is more important
than this and I'm going to come to you
Emily so be ready we want your ready uh
uh breakdown of the Southwest Airline is
under scrutiny for its customer of size
policy which allows overweight
passengers to request an additional seat
for free or book extra seats in advance
with a subsequent refund this policy has
drawn praise from some Tik Tock
influencers and a body positivity
Community critics CR critics argue that
this policy is unfair to passengers who
can comfortably fit into one seat and
represents a compromise driven by woke
activism over customers overall interest
they suggest that overweight passengers
should be required to purchase two seats
if they cannot fit into one rather than
receiving an extra seat what a dumb idea
but go ahead what what are your thoughts
on this I've said this on Gutfeld before
because this is not the first time
obesity is being woried and idolized in
the United States any other country
would be looked at gross cuz it is but
it just makes me regret ever dieting in
my life because if I was obese and
hideous I would have way more brand
deals and probably have a fat wallet
right now I'd get free seats apparently
on Southwest and my question is why are
we lying to ourselves that something
like obesity should be glorified and
when you said Tik Tok influencers it
like the light bulb went off in my head
like all right that's why it's being
normalized because of these freaking
idiots on Tik Tok and it it it goes Way
Beyond obesity it's like we're trying to
normalize things that they're not
normalized for a reason you know being
Fat's not healthy fat in your body is
likely going to cause cancer to produce
itself cells in your body CU it's not
healthy exercise is good for you eating
healthy is good for you glorifying
obesity which I see all the time on Tik
Tok is not like a new trend that we
should be setting and then secondly
they're trying to do this for I'm going
to assume like equality and stop like
fat shaming whatever fine body
positivity but here's what I've been
trying to say loudly if you want true
equality this goes to whether you're a
Jew a Christian Muslim an atheist black
white yellow purple fat skinny doesn't
matter you want equality stop pointing
out the differences you know you don't
need pride month you don't need your own
seat on a plane for free you don't need
to highlight the differences if you want
true equality got act normal e I'm sorry
like by the way she's a beautiful woman
imagine if she was thin healthy healthy
not thin healthy Let Her Go thin because
it ruins their entire agenda this story
just came out do you understand how much
that's going to backfire that means
really obes people are going to start
going on Southwest can you imagine the
nightmare if you're on that plane and
they're in the exit roll they're not
going to be able to help if hits
the fan they're going to be that's so
insensitive but it's true they asked you
like can you perform a by the way you
know when you're on Southwest Airlines
and you're just on your flight and you
ask the most important question the most
important question you got to ask is is
this a full flight they say no when they
say no if you're with another person
there's strategy they can pull you
somebody say window somebody sits aisle
and people come in and you say hey
somebody spilled coffee here coffee said
no they said no one sit here oh I don't
want to sit there and they go away and
so and then you try different things
okay yeah you know one person can say
this guy smells there's so many
different strategies you can take but
when it's a full flight and your time
we've been on these where we're sitting
there and you're just looking at a
person coming you're like oh God I'm
begging
you and then they say hi Oh my God how
are you I I really travel in Southwest
but I pick people out of the lineup and
um you I usually try to get on I hey you
guys want to team up to together let's
just sit together everybody imagine no I
get on and I try to sit as far forward
as cardio and so you know I I make sure
that I you know get wait can I point out
my my Southwest story I've never flown
in my life I had a really weird transfer
from Florida to DC and you H you've
never flown in your life no no Southwest
I'm a big Delta fan um so anyway when I
get to the plane I'm like boarding and
I'm like this flight looks really full
so I go and I didn't get my seat
assignment yet so I ask for it and they
go oh you're not guaranteed a seat on
the plane and I'm just like but I I was
build $480 for this ticket like so
where's my seat and they're like oh
buying a ticket doesn't guarantee you a
seat heard but what what was that what
does that mean so what did I just buy I
bought like a raffle that maybe I get on
the plane no I'm confused nobody
experienced that before on South I have
something I've had that happen before
wait what do you mean I literally bought
a ticket and they're like buying a
ticket doesn't guarantee you a seat on
the plane I swear this is South this was
Southwest it was myami to 100% I've
heard that happen before the biggest
problem that I have with this it's going
to result in
they got to bump somebody if someone
says I'm too big over let me say the
biggest problem I have with this is it
it's that the antithesis of what America
should be founded on which should be a
meritocracy the better you do the more
you read the more you learn the more you
try the more you stay in shape the
better the reward mechanism should be
the problem with this victim culture
right now
is they're rewarding the people that
shouldn't be rewarded and we have to use
language to cuddle them to make them
feel like so that now they're not fat or
obese they're customers of size of of
what size I have a size two it's just a
size exactly two or four not the reality
is you should be paying double your fat
ass is sitting in two seats pay double
but now you want to give them two free
seats what it's like you remember when
the people with like now we're going to
be doing a people who have have horrible
credit scores and have been laid on
their bills we're going to give them a
better mortgage price than the people
who actually have good credit scores
that been paying all their bills on time
it's backwards it's illogical no wonder
people are like sign up yeah by the way
when I sit next to someone and they're
like like obese I tell them off the Jump
cuz they're I'm like listen if you're
shoulder blubber and your tricep is L
I'm taking a nap on you I tell them I'm
like I'm going to use you what Rob were
you going to say something well as the
only I would say out of shaped person in
the
room Rob but you sell it I don't think
you qualify for two seats though no um
but I can tell you this you're a great
ass though go ahead started working out
eating healthy again and part of the
reason was because I took a flight and I
was uncomfortable in the one seat and I
went this is not a fun way to live
feeling uncomfortable all the time no
instead you're going to get a brand deal
exactly better than mine it ends up
making people it incentivizes bad
behavior because it doesn't give you any
effort to try and change your physical
being i instead of getting an extra seat
my my uh rout your mic on yeah I hear
him you hear him I hear him but I go
keep going my route was to start eating
healthy to start working out what's the
incentive if they're just going to
continue to cater for obious people and
make it easier and more accommodating
for them there's no reason for them to
try and change their bad habits and try
and lose weight and be
healthy you know what this vaults on you
bro my man Mage this buds for you of D
all right so let's go to the next one
next story here as
media more media layoffs ring in the New
York Americans face Prospect of news
dessert this is deep concerning folks
let's see what this is the media
industry is grappling with an alarming
surge in newsroom layoffs during the
holiday season further exacer exac
exacerbated exacerbated great word say
the word exacerbated
exacerbated oh you didn't get I guess I
did Emily you've been writing a lot of
stuff today you failed ex
exagerated your mark of job Cuts
prominent Outlets such as coni Nest geom
media Vice media and VOX media have
recently downsized their sta
contributing to a 48% increase in
journalism job Cuts in 2023 compared to
previous years the decline in media jobs
is attributed to the crumbling
advertising Revenue model and the
increasing Reliance on artificial
intelligence for Content creation
experts emphasize the urgency for public
and governmental support to sustain
journalism and prevent the emergence of
widespread news deserts deserts deserts
Victor yeah fun fact pbd desserts have
two s's cuz it's so good deserts One S
cuz nobody wants to live in the desert
you teach me
Engish for years I've been trying to do
this for you people are listening to
this you're distracting the out of
it but Victor Picard a media policy
Professor expects legislative efforts to
strengthen local journalism especially
at the state government level Tom
thoughts on the story first of all it's
the decline in ad revenue and AI is
hurting us we need the government to
help look at the underlying statement
here why is there a decline in ad
Revenue people aren't reading or buying
what you're publishing and so there's
there's less demand for it the other
part of this is is kind of about AI uh
about a week ago Ross levenson who was
the publisher of Sports Illustrated was
relieved of his position as part of an
acquisition but he was also relieved of
his position because Sports Illustrated
apparently and I know Ross wherever you
are Ross I hope you're doing well in the
next chapter's got good hair though is
that the guy yeah I had no clue actually
I love Ross what a great Ross is a good
guy I remember him from the early mobile
Wars and he was with Fox and he was a
good Ally in the early mobile Wars in uh
in Los Angeles um you know I I I was
rather you know as a colleague I was you
know I had a high uh opinion of him but
something happened here where they
created these AI generated reporters
with fake bios posted it as the writer
of the story and used AI to write the
stories now to me that sounds like a
cost-saving measure where you're just
trying to create now was creating a a
fake reporter how much a Ross know who
know I'm not to debate that but this is
an example where they were trying to use
AI to save money and write the stories
but what happened was um you know
somebody oh my gosh Adam is suddenly
break dancing in the middle of the
studio he's doing a
low you know I had that in me baby
anyway anyway back to more of those
deserts and there's an an underlying
thing here so number one you know they
fire Ross part of you know an m&a thing
and because they say there were AI
reporters that were writing stories so
it wasn't real and it was deceiving the
the subscribers okay fine but they were
trying to save money and using it but
the real issue here why does AD Revenue
decline you don't have enough people
watching it so that you can charge craft
to advertise the macaroni and cheese
that's it it's a very simple economics
craft says you got a whole bunch of of
moms on there and kids there then I'm
going to be advertising my mac and
cheese on you trust me and if it makes
my Mac and Cheese sell more I'm going to
buy even more ads that's not the problem
the problem is people is places like X
where a huge percent of people said that
they were using X as a news scrape or as
a news in the morning and guess what
people are getting news off social media
off news feeds off independent
newsletters and it's and increasingly
they don't go to their local newspaper
or to their favorite um thing I I enjoy
Business Insider this is not a plug but
it's Business Insider now not Insider
you want to know why because even they
were having a hard time getting
subscribers on Insider so they've laid
off a bunch of people right siiz the
organization they went back and they
called it Business Insider heading for
the niche with a smaller group it's
happening everywhere and there's a whole
lot of it that is due to social media uh
giving the stories immediately and
pretty compelling way so I don't wait
till tomorrow to see it from the LA
Times or Sports Illustrated I think
you're so right that the not the problem
but kind of the problem is the
accessibility I mean I'm 22 and when I
was like deciding my career path in
journalism 01 um my agent who I thought
was crazy at the time shout out to
werman um was like why is your goal to
work on X Network like I was like get me
a local news job then I'll grow up and
up and up and he's like you're starting
your own podcast and I was like are you
crazy no one's going to watch it but I
think the problem quote unquote is that
like I could become just avidly tweeting
on x and I could grow my following and
guess what I have my own audience which
means like then I'll bring in a sponsor
and grab my own Revenue but everyone
could do the same thing and then it's by
by the way I don't know any of those
listed any of those media companies I
probably have never even heard of them
not because I'm ignorant I just that's I
don't know I guess as a gen Z or I don't
see that you also have an informed point
of view on Israel and political things
that people would find to be newsworthy
and they would trust it right you would
be their news on that topic exactly but
I'm saying they would probably hear it
from me and my podcast and and and my
microphone wherever that may be it's not
going to be like on your traditional
Medias cuz now you don't need to
technically watch the news anymore to
find out the news like I'm always on the
go all you guys and nobody's sitting
here home all day you're on X you're on
Instagram you're on maybe you have like
some news app on your phone and it's
likely one channel not like three or
four that you're alternating between so
why would they not go out of business
cuz social media is the future my
agent's been saying it for 5 years and
he's right they're taking over who who's
going to sit home and watch TV all day
anyone guys you guys are worried about
what she did she scare you a little bit
is SC News Room The News Room I coign
her message she's and by the way here's
the other by the way you know a a if a
52-year-old heard what she just said
they're so not happy with what she just
said I know by the way I explain to a
lot of older people Med they are not
happy about this because she's right
yeah and that's the direction it's going
and these teleprompter gangsters that
are up there reading what somebody else
wrote we saw what happened when there
was the strike with writers strike and
actor strike and what Jimmy Fallon kemel
a lot of these guys couldn't do what
they were doing because the writers
Couldn't Write the jokes like holy
I'm not funny anymore right what do I do
now right I can't entertain people
anymore the podcast game is a very
different game it's very very hard very
hard to do and some of these guys going
to have to compete in that Marketplace
and it's going to be cat rhic for many
of them filtering process is here and
it's a beautiful thing and we'll see
who's going to Survive who's not going
to survive so by the way I also I love
Community notes because they've been
doing such a good job trying to Twitter
yeah like whatever X Twitter they're
trying to like limit the misinformation
by understanding this is the future of
our news sources so the least they can
do is community notes the F out of
everyone fantastic let's go to I want to
do three more stories we got yeah we got
time for three more stories do we hit
the Border first do we hit uh um what
you call it Minnesota with Stephen A
Smith do we hit U Pick the story pick
one of the three the Minnesota's not
even a story like someone's text got
leaked good shouldn't have been her
business next like what what why is
there even a story like I'm so sick of
athletes being like getting into the
personal life unless they're beating
their wife or punching someone in the
face on the court or off the court their
personal life should not be our business
you just offended Adam Adam go ahead
because this is something very upset
with the story go ahead Adam I beat my
wife oh my God
I'm not Smith Anthony Edwards text
message leak it's none of our damn
business so um ESPN Express is concerned
uh Stephen A Smith over the controversy
involving Minnesota timber star Anthony
Edwards listen I know there's not a big
Sports audience out there but this is
actually a uh cultural conversation
about abortions what's going on with
probably one of the leading MV MVP
candidates in the NBA right now Anthony
Edwards who was the best player on the
uh USA team over the summer uh in the in
the the world closest thing to Michael
Jordan in the NBA right now yeah okay
not even tell me who today tell me I
thought you said he is my bad he is the
closest thing to Michael Jordan in the
game today today there is no too soon to
be talking like that but give me a name
of somebody in the NBA today that's got
the closest game to Michael today game
style there's no not any it would
probably be him I mean obviously it's
he's a poor man's Jordan but I who do
you put ahead I don't put anyone I don't
like that comparison sty I don't mean to
offend you it's just anyway our friend
how could I live that's the one thing
she got offended by today Free Speech
absolutist but don't call don't question
Michael Jordan so he's facing backlash
because uh um private text messages were
leaked revealing that he encouraged an
abortion um with this girl that he was
casually dating and he sent her hundred
grand she was an Instagram model so you
can imagine what she looks like um
Stephen aith responds because he does
that with every situation out there let
me say this Anthony Edwards had to
apologize only only because he's a
public figure Smith questioned the
repercussions faced by individuals who
expose private messages in the public
essentially doxing I'm wondering why
some law is going to come into the place
where people like Anthony Edwards and
others can retaliate legally for folks
putting their private messages on blast
it's none of our business he emphasized
that they need to protect priv privacy
rights in such situations so the story
long and short is he knocked her up she
there was text messages basically saying
she's he's like so what you going to do
with that thing and she and she's like I
don't know she was able here's 100 Grand
he's like yeah I have the abortion she's
like $100,000 Jes yeah well her whole
thing was she said that she had an
abortion two years ago um where it would
have been a boy she said I lost my son
um and now I regret it lost lost him or
killed him years ago exactly no that's
what's going on now but she's telling
him the reason I don't want to get an
abortion today is cuz that I got swen
also read the sea K Playbook it's called
have the child get child support contact
an agent and see if you can get she's
know but here's a she's wearing a
wedding ring and her bottom lip was bit
by a bee look at that you know welcome
to Instagram model life but the reality
is he already sent her the 100 Grand oh
okay and then afterward she starts
looking the text messages what a rookie
50 now 50 later but I feel bad if this
kid ever is born I mean we're in social
media nothing gets deleted he's gonna
grow up and they be like you know what
happened how while you're alive you know
your father wanted to abort you your
mother like that's the reality of the
situation today and that's her fault
listen if people want to be pro-life if
people want to be pro-choice cool it's
all good do that behind closed doors but
the fact that you're putting people on
blast and basically sort of like
blackmailing them into disgusting into
making sure that you can have this baby
no wonder iron hates us I'm I'm joking
um not funny no but like be being the
only one with estrogen in this room I
hope
um sorry no I just think that there's
two separate issues the the morality of
of airing someone's Private Business
which is to me just wrong it's like
clout chasing 101 like this girl is
horrible I think like she's disgusting
woman and your child's going to be
humiliated that's the point you brought
up but B it's like it's not our business
and then see it's like the only reason
it's an issue is because like you said
it's part of the left agenda like oh
normalize abortion blah blah blah and
she was trying to air that but like I
just think do whatever you want to do
like as someone I think abortion is
horrible and I would never put myself in
a situation to need one I think someone
needs to do a better job talking to
these like why every why are NBA players
always knocking girls up why is this
always a story why does zion have like
eight baby mamas coming out saying oh he
knocked me up too and I got an abortion
like it's really not that hard to not
get someone pregnant in today's day and
age and instead this shit's happening
because people are stupid and chasing
clout you know who you're sleeping with
I'm sorry look how she looks does that
not scream I want to get Knocked Up and
post it and steal your money for the
next 18 years I mean she looks like a
perfectly classy girl what do you I saw
a girl like that at church on Sunday I
saw that same exact look at church I'm
so going to get bodying look at that
you're asking why by the way she may
qualify for two seats on
Southwest look at that
yes or no right you can't fit that in
one that's called a twofer and and maybe
what she's saying is they need to change
like can you imagine like if they Staple
Center or some of these Arenas they
change their name welcome to the Trojan
Center
uh they got to do it they got to Magnum
centero Magnum Center Trojan Center you
ask you ask why these guys knock these
girls up I mean you know that I have
friends in the NBA and I've been around
this world there's something called uh
Jersey Chasers or Cleat Chasers or
Jersey jumpers or homie hoppers
this is their business model they're hot
they're Instagram
models keep
putting put your pants back on they
might not be your version of hot but
there was a guy that you know called Sir
Mix A Lot that had a song called Baby
Got Back and he said I want a girl that
got buns son so that's what these guys
are into this these are the Instagram
type models that these NBA guys are
basically surrounding with I get you
know after the game there's called
postgame passes I go down there cuz I've
you know been with friends and do all
that you see the girls obviously that
are get the postgame passes they're not
the wives they're not the girlfriends
they're these girls they get a couple
extra passes after the game you know uh
Anthony Edwards he plays in Minnesota
believe me if he's in Miami or in
Phoenix or Dallas for a couple nights
these girls show up to the game he's
repopulated I'm just letting I'm just
letting you know he's enjoying his time
off I just don't understand why you
don't wrap it up homie cuz it feels
better the other way that's what it
feels better well I hope you feel better
cutting $100,000 checks or you know
alimony or child support Sean Kemp needs
to do like a oneon-one course and get up
there and say Guys these are how many
kids that Sean Kemp have he had a lot of
I had through and it and it basically
bankrupted him thanks for looking up
homie hopper Rob see that again Sean
Kamp has how many kids Sean km have one
the best a chart did I just see a chart
of kids yeah coming in you know you're
putting in work when there's a chart he
has to much work seven children with six
different women let of Mercy have said
he's got six kids with seven different
women doing a math anyways let's go to
the next story this is great you know
let's go to the last one here over 170
people with Epstein links likely to be
named in court doc set to be un unsealed
in upcoming weeks and let's see this
here Manhattan federal judge Loretta
presca who needs hardcore protection by
the way
has ordered the release of long sealed
court documents in a defamation lawsuit
filed by Jeffrey epy accuser Virginia
Roberts uh against galain Maxwell in
2015 this decision will likely lead to
the identification of 17 individuals
associated with Epstein some of whom
have previously been referred to as Jane
does or John does in court filing the
this ruling the ruling gives these
individuals 14 days to appeal and it
mentions that some of them have already
spoken public about their connections to
Epstein either as former employees or
victims name of some of the individuals
involved such as these uh those
mentioned the Epstein little black book
are considered public figures so
interesting this judge could be a
billionaire in the next few weeks if she
wanted to she needs protection um all of
these guys are talking to each other
right now saying what do we do I wonder
what Leon black is doing right and maybe
he needs some Estate
Planning and his lawyer better do
something about this or otherwise he
could get
killed yeah but you think they're
actually going to let cuz this is like
this is this is big this is big cuz
they're saying a bunch of the people
that were helping the victims the
stories everything's going to be start
coming out after the New Year well Jesse
Waters asked RFK and RFK said he was on
the plane twice and it was with his wife
and his kids because his wife was
friends with galain and he came out and
said I want this thing to be public so
everybody knows about the flight I want
everybody to know who those names are go
ahead and do it these are flights to the
island or just flights with him
people Epstein links to be named what
that means no one knows those are two
different things makes a good point
because RFK supposedly was linked to him
because he was they were hitting up for
charitable donations and the Kennedy
foundation and that's rfk's Point make
it all public make it all out there my
wife were on the plane this guy was a
player moving money around for Charities
and for political purposes and so twice
I was own is playing with them nothing
to see here broadcast it put it out
there that's why I believe RFK on that
other people that don't want let's put
it this way if the plane was going north
and south from West Palm Beach to New
York and it was charitable and it was at
the same time they're doing the Kennedy
Center you know uh fundraisers and stuff
okay but if you're on the plane that's
going east and west you probably have
some problems yeah you got something to
hide you have something to hide it
doesn't well it doesn't help when Dick
Durban is trying to block subpoena to
find out like here's the thing Name by
the way protect the pedophiles yeah dick
hey Adam what happened last week I got
dick Durban but listen my point is
didn't mark wber play him but by the way
this has been going on for how long we
have gay Maxwell the fact that not
everything is out in the open cuz listen
explain yourself I could see Tom before
he got like arrested and you know people
now know that he's a pedophile and he's
a sex trafficker if you were flying
there to the island after like you got
to explain yourself you know he's a
pedophile you know he's arrested for for
trafficking kids why are you going there
bill because went in 93 is when he said
his flight Records Was 93 before any of
this was public I think we just need to
understand that we that we can't just
basically make people guilty before
they've been proven innocent or do pro
gu that's a new new trend in America of
course and that and that's my point
because we want to make everybody guilty
and then just say if you've been on a
flight with Epstein or even been to his
Island then you should go to jail well
you know who's going to jail Donald
Trump Bill Clinton pedop Allan Greenspan
RFK so it's Nuance cuz a lot of these
people were probably blackmailed by
Epstein right we've done the Playbook
where like hey you come have a good time
everything by the way then he's like but
you yeah there's a camera in the
bathroom there's a camera in your
bedroom there's a camera so a lot of it
was a setup TR a hatchet job something
like that so it does take some nuanced
but anyone who just was on a plane with
Epstein isn't guilty of anything what
did they do on that island is that think
we need to find out true and let's hear
the people that were there K here we go
that's the show two hours Emily Austin
good to have you on thanks for having me
where can people find you your show uh
my show is called The Hoop chats
primarily on socials you could find me
Emily Austin on Instagram emily. Austin
Twitter at Emily R Austin but if she
wants to give me my username back I'll
take it um and uh I'm banned from Tik
Tok but you could find me at Emily R
Austin you're banned from Tik Tok there
you go I'm a Zionist guys can we put
some of that stuff below so people can
find it tomorrow we got Kobe Covington
in the house take care everybody we'll
see you guys tomorrow bye- bye
bye-bye